after nine eleven I went back because
there was this interesting phenomenon
that happened which was a huge uptick in
the number of second-generation Muslim
immigrant youth women starting to wear
the hijab now let me break that down by
second generation I mean born in the
United States grown up here their entire
lives a lot of more in their late teens
early 20s did not wear the hijab before
nine eleven but started wearing it after
I had two students who were working for
me on a project at the time who were not
wearing the hijab and they started
wearing it much to the dismay of their
family which again goes against the
stereotype that this is something that's
forced on these Muslim women that's not
the case at all by and large especially
in the United States and when I asked
them why would you do this right after
nine eleven when there's such heightened
tension and many of them said you know
I'm an American I've always been in
America and I was born and raised here
but the treatment I've received after
nine eleven makes me feel like I'm not a
part of America so they were searching
for an identity that they could feel
like they fit another woman said to me
well you know I've got friends who liked
me before nine eleven but now our sort
of don't know what to do with me because
I'm Muslim they so she said I want to
show them that I can be a good Muslim a
good American and still a good friend so
it's a very interesting dynamic but I
think it is very very misunderstood by
and large in terms of what it means and
it means something different here in the
US to different communities and it even
does in different countries in the
Middle East where there are laws
prohibiting it in some places laws
demanding it in others so it requires a
deeper look into what the hijab means
for the women themselves in the
different contexts in which they're
wearing them